la ciudad del Primer Ministro de Japón
fuegida está paralizada con un operativo
de seguridad de más de 24.000 agentes
por la Cumbre del g7 y la llegada del
presidente de Ucrania las principales
avenidas de la ciudad las vimos
completamente desolada tras el operativo
de seguridad japonés que no se puede
permitir errores tras lo ocurrido el año
pasado con el ex primer ministroave los
oficiales impedían la libre circulación
de vehículos al confirmarse la visita
así como reforzaron la seguridad en el
aeropuerto y las principales estaciones
de trenes de la ciudad todos los
espacios se revisaban minuciosamente se
les llegó a Hiroshima en la tarde hora
local tras confirmarse en la mañana su
presencia prevista inicialmente fuera de
forma online este segundo día de la
jornada del g7 ha estado centrada en la
seguridad económica la dependencia
comercial de China y la colaboración con
países emergentes sin embargo esto se
ocupa un poco tras la llegada de
zelensky por otro lado el grupo afirmó
que tomará medidas para invertir en sus
propias economías y reducir las
excesivas dependencias con china sin que
esto busque obstaculizar el crecimiento
económico del país asiático también el
Primer Ministro se reunió en la mañana
con su homólogo de Brasil Lula da Silva
donde afirmó que le dará un préstamo de
30 mil millones de yenes para el sector
salud